but I saw a documentary when I was in
San Antonio on HBO and it's about Carrie
Fisher and her mom and I cried during it
do you know why why well you know how
you know that they're dead right yes but
Gilbert doesn't know [ __ ] that's true
but you know I do know not dumb but
you're just like you know I don't know
nothing very smart
no you just walk around I don't know no
yeah yeah yeah yeah they died a day
apart yeah but what I didn't know is is
that they had been virtually living with
each other for 20 years I didn't know
that like they were there are houses are
connected oh she was taking care of her
mom no vice versa vice versa they were
both taken care of each other and her
brothers very highly involved in their
lives and now in that when you look at
that you just it just make it becomes
sadder you know like if my mom died
after I died the day after it'd be
really sad but like I see her like three
times a year you know decease and that's
now you know why she dies she couldn't
live without her oh man I'm gonna say
something right now man cuz I didn't
even know about her mom really Debbie
Reynolds I [ __ ] she is [ __ ] Talent
I mean not even know I be in the [ __ ]
50s and 60 MGM years good morning good
morning and then like some white dude
would pick her up by the neck and she
would tap-dance on a [ __ ] piano you
know what she didn't give a [ __ ] right
she would like do like spins on her back
in the mud like she's doing a Western I
mean she is legitimately super she
reminds me of my friend Nicole Parker
was on MADtv with me like can sing and
dance and act triple damn it not only
that right she could do live
performances Broadway but no not
Broadway nightclub oh she would go into
the audience and tell jokes and riff
like I respect that so much and then um
she made Carrie Fisher sing when she was
14 and Carrie Fisher had a good voice
do you know that yes she would sing in a
deeper kind of more she could have been
a singer I thing if you like developed
her skill and um yeah it's just and then
just use a lot of drugs and resentment
and their [ __ ] dad was a piece of
[ __ ] Eddie Fisher yeah she left the
family for Elizabeth Taylor because she
was a neighbor yeah but then later on
Elizabeth Taylor and Debby became really
good friends yeah they did and then
later on Eddie Fisher became virtually
homeless really he became destitute so
it just it's just a really good
documentary I just love to see and you
know what it couldn't just say something
loud and the last thing I want to say
about it is that it gave me a sense of
empowerment because um there was this
thing right right when carrie fisher's
doing Star Wars and she's just like
she's now at a convention and she's like
um I'm about to give celebrity lap
dances you know and she goes out and she
charges money to sign up you know mean
posters yeah and she takes photos and
she thinks it's like being a stripper
but it's like it's yeah but it's like
how I feel sometimes you know when I'm
like why do distributing but like you
know there is a there is a sense of like
you know when I go on and you know after
the show and you take photos I like
seeing my fans and I like seeing the
people showed up I'm really grateful by
it but there is a sense of like you know
it's it doesn't feel that mystique that
you know being a you know you know not a
celebrity but somebody that's known I'm
sure you it loses its excitement after
you get approached you know daily right
yeah but I'm also I feel like I'm nice I
feel like not here I really extreme I
really like you know them and I wanted
to photos they pick me up they do to
pick me up and put me on their shoulders
and they treat me like I'm kind of like
a child like an object like a trophy or
something and I bear it you know I go
yeah
yes squeeze my ass when we're taking a
photo like dudes would like just as a
joke grab my ass you know I don't say
anything I just kind of go oh you endure
sexual harassment on a DVD yes but
they're watching Carrie Fisher do it
like you're needing to do it too today
ham rant like you know doing the road
for me you know I'm out doing show
sometimes like Saturday was great but
Friday there was like one show was like
80 people I was bad in front of in a 3 5
400 seat venue oh right and I'm out
there like really trying you know to get
them to like me and to I want to put on
a good show but it's hard you know but
then watching Carrie Fisher grind it out
made me go oh everyone kind of has to do
it everyone's in there oh yeah hustling
and I don't feel bad about it I like it
now I just you know when you see it I
just I like seeing it and and I just you
know it was a really good documentary
you know was cute and made me sad that
the guy had a part she couldn't live
without him and then the Sun now is like
everyone's gone now what is he doing
what that were me I would if I lost my
mom and sister and I was in my let's say
like 60s and I didn't have children or
anything like that I would I would take
a [ __ ] ton of more [ __ ] weights and
peace out yeah but he but he has a kid
he also gets everything
oh he's because like Debbie Reynolds has
like she's I don't know if you know this
but she collected and bought over the
last 50 years
um memorabilia mm-hmm like she sold she
had you know that infamous um was the
blonde lady with the [ __ ] Marilyn
Monroe that's her name with Marilyn
Monroe's dress you know how she's on the
subway that that she had that dress yeah
and she sold it for like six million
dollars whoa yeah but she collected it
over the years you know man
she would like go to snakes Sinatra's
house it could I have yours
tuxedo said why don't I sell it if 52
yeah she was always like no she didn't
want old Hollywood to disappear anyway
that's that
yeah memorabilia here that's worth more
than let's say 500 memorabilia right
here that naked photo over 600,000
that's the only one of it exists yeah oh
look at that Kim Jung Woon right there
that's the only one $20 yet if I often
it by one I can get $30 for that more
[Music]